hey guys Ryan right over here dance I've
already here Slendy god damn it you're
shooting so we're gonna check out this
trailer for slender the arrival launch
trailer great a teen for blood violence
I don't know there's like eight slender
games I played this one just got
released played slender anxiety together
check it out let's do it rated T for
teen I can see that no I'm sorry you hit
me and I couldn't see scope death see it
no it's addiction sensory phenomena you
were so good it is described as the
ability to sense when you were being
watched
and he dismiss in a superstition
others know
VCR play
wow this is really trippy I this is
really are you like my damn
/ that reminds me of Japanese horror
films yeah dude yeah I think of like the
original ring and the ring and you know
jus on or the garage or some other
Japanese titles because it has it like
haunting menacing tone of like silence
and then slender even looks like [ __ ] it
he looks like one of those kinds of yeah
creatures you know with the no mouth
okay like if that was a trailer I didn't
think it was gonna be that big of a deal
but like that pop you know it was really
really intense and I like the setup of
saying that interesting vocabulary word
which I think we learn something today
but I think it was completely wasted on
you about how you know people dismiss it
as superstition but those who know
better know they are being watched and
that is a terrifying way to introduce
you into this yeah I also now have that
exact thing yes we played slender right
played slender anxiety yeah yeah yeah we
were not good yeah - [ __ ] his pants I
pissed mine his friend got a period
blood stain on his couch yeah Jacob
totally taken Jacob got Barry alright
hold on I gotta make sure I wasn't crazy
I wasn't ah he flashed before the whole
thing even started dan you you have
solved the mystery did I solve slender
guys you son is like everything is look
if you bought the game get a refund I
solve it yeah there you go guys we did
it welcome to the real rejects anyway
dudes and gals and animals who have
access to computers because you are
super advanced and science is doing
experiments on you
and or cats and or cats if you knew the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects by clicking that button and you
can check out dansgaming channel where
he plays video games and other kinds of
electronics you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter
where we do like posts posts are fun
posts get us to connect with you on a
more personal level
yeah youtuber talk promoted my should
electronics I got a really good let's
play easy bake up and coming out with
that was waiting alone I kept talking
baby Ford an interrupt me so he could
say whatever he was getting at one show
it was not